so welcome Andre I'm really glad you
could join me today yeah thank you for
having so a lot of people already know
your work in deep learning but not
everyone knows your personal story so
like to Austin start by you know telling
us how did you end up doing all this
work in deep learning yeah absolutely so
I think my first exposure to deep
learning was when I was an undergraduate
at the University of Toronto and so Jeff
Fenton was there and he was teaching a
class on be performing and at the time
it was a restricted Boltzmann machines
trained on amnesty Jets and I just
really like the way I'm kind of Jeff I
talked about training the network like
the mind of the network and he was using
these terms and I just thought it would
there was a kind of a flavor of
something magical happening when when
this was training on those digits and
and so that's kind of like my first
exposure to it although I didn't get
into it in a lot of detail at that time
and then when I was doing my master's
degree at University of British Columbia
I took a class with meta decorators and
that was again on machine learning and
that's the first time I kind of dealt
kind of deeper into these networks and
so on
and kind of what was interesting is that
I was very interested in artificial
intelligence and sweat two classes and
artificial intelligence but a lot of
what I was seeing there was just very
not satisfying like it was a lot of kind
of you know death or surge breadth-first
search
alpha beta pruning and all these things
and I was like not understanding out
like I was not satisfied and so when I
was seeing neural networks for the first
time like and in machine learning which
is kind of this term that I think is
more technical and not as well known in
kind of you know most people talk about
artificial intelligence machine learning
was more kind of a technical term I
would almost say and so I was
dissatisfied with artificial
intelligence and when I saw machine
learning I was like this is the AI that
I want to kind of spend time on this is
what's really interesting and and that's
kind of what took me down those
directions is that this is kind of
almost a new computing paradigm I would
say because normally humans write code
but here in this case we write the
optimization rights code and so you're
creating input-output specification and
then you have lots of examples of it and
then the optimization rights code and
sometimes it can write code better than
you and so I thought that was just a
very new kind of way of thinking about
programming and that's what kind of
intrigued me about it then through a
work one of the things you've come to be
known for is that you are now the human
benchmark for the image net
emission classification competition how
did that come about so basically their
image net challenge is kind of a it's
sometimes compared to kind of the world
cup of computer vision so a lot of
people kind of care about this benchmark
and number our error rate kind of goes
down over time and it was not obvious to
me in kind of where a human would be on
the scale and I've done a similar
smaller scale experiment on see part 10
dataset earlier so what I did then see
part 10 is I just was looking at these
32 by 32 images and I was trying to
classify them myself at the time this
was only 10 categories so it's fairly
simple to create an interface for it and
I think I had an error rate of about 6
percent on that and so that was and then
based on what I was seeing and how hard
task was I think I predicted that the
lowest error rate we've achieved would
be like okay I can't exactly merge I
think I guess like 10% and we're now
down to like 3 or 2% or something crazy
so that was my first kind of a fun
experiment of like human baseline and
and I thought it was really important
for the same purposes that you kind of
point out in some of your lectures I
mean you really want that number to
understand you know how well humans are
doing in so we could compare machine
learning algorithms to it and for
imagenet it seemed that there was a
discrepancy between how important is
mention was and how much focus there
wasn't getting a lower number and us not
understanding even how humans are doing
on this benchmark and so I created this
a JavaScript interface and I was showing
myself the images and then the problem
with image net is you don't have just
ten categories you have a thousand and
so it was call most like a UI challenge
of obviously I can't remember a thousand
categories so how do I make it so that
it's something fair and so I listed out
all the categories and I gave myself
examples of them so for each image I was
crawling through a thousand categories
and just trying to kind of you know see
based on the examples I was seeing for
each category what this image might be
and I thought it was a just an extremely
instructed exercise by itself I mean I
was not I did not understand that like a
third of omission at his dogs and like
dog species and so that was kind of
interesting to see that the network
spends a huge amount of time caring
about dogs I think a third of its
performance comes from dogs and yeah so
this was kind of something that I did
for maybe a week or two I put everything
else on hold I thought it was kind of a
very fun exercise I got a number in the
end and then I thought that one person
is not enough I wanted to have multiple
people and so I was trying to organize
within a lab to get other people to kind
of do the same thing and I think people
are not as willing to contribute say
like a week or two of like pretty
painstaking work you know just like yeah
sitting down for like five hours and
trying to figure out which dog treat
this is and so I was not able to get
like enough data in that respect but we
got at least like some approximate
performance which I thought was was fun
and then this was kind of picked up and
it's uh it wasn't obvious to me at the
time I just want to know the number but
this became like a thing and people
really liked the fact that that this
happened and I'm referred to jokingly as
like the reference human and of course I
that's kind of a hilarious to me yeah
well you what were you surprised when
you know software defense finally
surpass your performance absolutely so
yeah absolutely
um I mean especially I mean sometimes
it's really hard to see in the image
where it is is just like a tiny blob of
like a black black dog is obviously
somewhere there and I'm not seeing like
you know I'm guessing between like 20
categories and the network just gets it
and I don't understand how that comes
about so there's some super humanists to
it but also for the I think the network
is extremely good at these kind of like
statistics of like four types and
textures and just I think in that
respect I was not surprised that the
network could better measure those fine
statistics across lots of images in many
cases I was surprised because some of
the images required you to read like
it's just a bottle and you can't see
what it is but it actually tells you
what it is in text and so as a human I
can read it and it's fine but the
network would have to learn to read to
identify the object because it wasn't
obvious just from from it um you know
one of the things you've become
well-known for and that the deep
learning committee has been grateful to
you for has been your teaching the Santa
Clause and putting now online tell me a
bit about how that came about yeah
absolutely so I think I felt very
strongly that basically this technology
was transformative and that a lot of
people want to use it it's almost like a
hammer and what I wanted to do I was in
a position to randomly kind of hand out
this hammer to a lot of people and I
just found that very compelling it's not
like necessarily advisable from the
perspective of a PhD student because
you're putting
research on hold I mean this became like
hundred and twenty percent of my time
and I had to put all of research on hold
for maybe I mean I taught the class
twice and each time it's maybe four
months and so that time is basically
spent entirely on the class so it's not
super advisable from that perspective
but it was basically the highlight of my
PhD is not even likely related to
research I think teaching the class was
definitely the highlight of my PhD just
just seeing the students just the fact
that they were really excited it was a
very different class normally you're
being taught things that were discovered
in 1800 or something like that
but we were able to come to class and
say look there's this paper from like a
week ago or even like yesterday and
there's new results and I think the
undergraduate students and any other
students they just really enjoyed that
aspect of the class and the fact that
they actually understood so there's not
you know so you don't have to this is
not nuclear physics or rocket science
this is like you need to know calculus
and linear algebra and you can actually
kind of understand everything that
happens under the hood and so I think
just the fact that it's so powerful the
fact that it's that it keeps changing on
a daily basis if people kind of felt
like they're on the forefront of
something big and I think that's why
people like really enjoyed that class a
lot yeah and and and you've really
helped a lot of people and a lot of
hammers yeah you know as someone there's
been and doing deep learning for quite
some time now
the field is evolving rapidly a bit
crazy here how is your own thinking how
is your understanding of deep learning
change over these you know many years
yeah it's basically like when I was
seeing we're circling Boltzmann machines
for the first time on digits it wasn't
obvious to me how this technology was
going to be used and how big of a deal
it would be and also when I was starting
to work on computer vision convolutional
networks they were around but they were
not something that a lot of the computer
vision community kind of anticipated
using anytime soon the I think the
perception was that this works for small
cases but would never scale to large
images and that was just extremely
incorrect and so basically I'm just
surprised by how general technology is
and how good the results are that was my
largest surprise I would say and it's
not only that so that's one thing that
it worked so well and say like imagenet
but the other thing that I think no one
saw coming or at least for sure I did
not see coming is that you can take
these pre train networks and that you
can transfer you can fine-tune them on
arbitrary other tasks because now you're
not just solving imagenet and you need
millions of examples this also happens
to be
very general feature extractor and I
think that's kind of a second inside
that I think fewer people saw coming and
you know there were there were these
papers that are just like here all the
things that people have been working on
in computer vision I seen classification
and action recognition object
recognition you know face attributes and
so on and people are just kind of
crushing each task just by fine-tuning
the network and so that to me was very
surprising
yeah and somehow I guess supervised
learning gets most of the press and even
though retraining fine tuning transfer
learning is actually working very well
people seem to talk less about the
episode right yeah yeah I think what has
not worked as much as some of these
hopes are on unsupervised learning which
I think has kind of been really why a
lot of researchers have gotten into the
field in around 2000 in 2007 and so on
and I think the promise of that has
still not been delivered and I think I I
found that I find that also surprising
is that the supervised learning part
worked so well and the answer prize
learning is still kind of in a state of
uh-huh yeah it's still not obvious how
it's going to be used or how that's
going to work even though a lot of
people are still deep believers I would
say to use the term in the in this area
so I know that you know one of the
presidents wasn't thinking a lot about
the long-term future of AI share your
thoughts on that so I spent the last
maybe year in a half at opening I kind
of thinking a lot about these topics and
it seems to me like the field will kind
of split into two trajectories one will
be kind of a kind of applied AI which is
kind of just making these neural
networks training them mostly with
supervised learning potentially
unsurprised learning and getting better
say image recognizer zones or something
like that and I think the other will be
kind of artificial general intelligence
directions which is kind of how do you
get neural networks that are entire kind
of dynamical system that thinks and
speaks and can do everything that a
human can do and as intelligent in that
way and I think that what's been
interesting is that for example in
computer vision the way we approached it
in the beginning I think was wrong in
that we tried to break it down by
different parts so we were like okay
humans recognize people humans recognize
scenes you can recognize objects so
we're just going to do everything that
humans do and then once we have all
those things and now we have like
different areas and once we have all
those things we're gonna figure out how
to put them together and I think that
was kind of a wrong approach and we've
seen that how that kind of played out
historically and so I think there's
something similar that's going on
slightly on the higher level of with AI
so kind of people are asking well okay
people plan people do experiments to
figure out how the world works or people
talk to other people so when you
language and people are trying to
decompose it by function accomplish each
piece and then put it together into some
kind of brain and I just think it's kind
of a just incorrect approach and so what
I've been a much bigger fan of is having
not decomposing that way but having a
single kind of neural network there is
the complete dynamical system that
you're always working with a full agent
and then the question is how do you
actually create objectives such that
when you optimize over the weights to
make up that brain you get intelligent
behavior out and so that's kind of been
something that I've been thinking about
a lot at opening I I think there are a
lot of kind of different area ways that
people have thought about approaching
this problem so for example going in a
supervised learning direction I have
this essay online it's not an essay it's
kind of a short story that I wrote and
the short story kind of tries to come up
with a hypothetical world of what it
might look like if the way we approach
this AGI is just by scaling up
supervised learning which we know works
and and so that gets into something that
looks like Amazon Mechanical Turk or
people association to lots of robot
bodies and they perform tasks and then
we train on that as a supervised
learning data set to imitate humans and
what that might look like and so on and
so then there are other directions like
on surprised learning from algorithmic
information theory things like a ixi or
from artificial life things that look
more like artificial evolution and
that's kind of where I spend my my time
thinking a lot about and I think I had a
correct answer but I'm not willing to
reveal it here so you've already given
out a lot of hammers and today there are
a lot of people still wanting to enter
the field of AR entity learning so for
people in that position what advice do
you have for them yeah so I think when
people talk to me about CS 231 and and
why they
thought it was a very useful course what
people what I keep hearing again and
again is just people appreciate the fact
that we got all the way to the low-level
details and they were not working with a
library they saw the route code and they
saw how everything was implemented and
implemented chunks of it themselves and
so just going all the way down to the
and understanding everything under you
and never it's really important to not
abstract away things like you need to
have a full understanding of the whole
stack and that's where I learned the
most myself as well when I was learning
this stuff it's just implementing it
myself from scratch was the most
important it was the piece that that I
felt gave me the best kind of a bang for
the buck in terms of understanding so I
wrote my own library it's called comm
Nijs it was written in JavaScript and
implements convolutional neural networks
that was my way of learning about back
propagation and so that's something that
I keep advising people is that that you
not work with tensorflow or something
else you can work with it once you have
written it something something yourself
on the lowest detail you understand
everything under you and now you are
comfortable to you know it's possible to
use some of these frameworks that
abstract some of it away from you but
you know what's under the hood and so
that's been something that helped me the
most that's something that people
appreciate the most when they take 231
and and that's when I would devise a lot
of people yeah yeah and it's some kind
of a sequence of layers and I know that
when I add some drop out layers it makes
it work better like that's not what you
want in that case you're you're not
going to be able to debug effectively
you're not going to be able to improve
on models effectively you know what dads
are really glad that you've learned on
the iCore starts off with that many
weeks of Python programming first yeah
good good thank you very much for
sharing your insights and advice you're
already a hero to many people in the
deep learning world so really glad
really grateful you could join us here
today yeah thank you for having